ما يقترب الليل هنا في العاصمه الاكرانيه
كيف تتضاعف كثيرا مخاوف سكنا كيف من تجدد
القصف على مدينتهم سواء بيع صواريخ او
الطائرات المسيره اليوم فقط تم اطلاق سفره
الانذار اكثر من ثلاث مرات على ما يبدو ان
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه وحسب ما
اكدته في بيان رصد الطائرات مقاتله روسيه
حلقت من الحدود البيلاروسيا لم يعرف
اتجاهها لهذا امر في المكان الذي كنا فيه
بالنزول الى القبور بقينا هناك اكثر من
ثلاث ساعات اختلمنا الفرصه للحديث مع
الاوكرانيين الذين كانوا موجودين في القمه
الخوف والماسات والمعاناه باديه على
وجوههم في الليل تخوف كبير من القصف
العديد من العائلات الاوكرانيه هنا في كيف
تقضي ليله في محطات المترو وفي الملاجيء
خوفا من تجدد وتكرر العمليات او الهجوم
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه وفي الصباح تبدا
معاناه اخرى
وهي انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وشح المياه
لك ان تتخيل لرمضان في هذا البرد والشتاء
القارس جدا درجات الحراره تصل هنا الى سته
وسبعه درجات تحت الصفر بدون تيار كهربائي
لاكثر من 65
ساعات هنا الاوكرانيون متخوفون كثيرا
كثيرا من من الحدود البيلاروسيه ومن ممكن
ان ياتي من الحدود كلهم يتحدثون على
المناورات العسكريه هناك بين الجيش الروسي
وبين الجيش بلا روسي او يتحدثون كثيرا
كثيرا هنا على اللقاء الاخيره الذي جمع
الرئيس الروسيه في وادي ميرفت نظيره بلا
روسي
يقولون ان الهدف الغير معلن للسياره الا
هو محاوله
اكثر في العمليه التي يتوقعونها العمليه
الميدانيه التي يقولون انها سوف تبدا في
مطلع العام الجريمه
مدير احد نعم عبد القادر في هذه
بالحديث عن هذه الزياره هناك زياره تتم في
هذه الاثناء الى واشنطن هي الاولى للرئيس
زنسكي الى هذا البلد هل تحدثتم الى
الاوكرانيين ما هي الاصداء في في اوساط
الاوكرانيين حول ذهاب الرئيس الى خارج
البلاد لاول مره وذهبه الى واشنطن تحديدا
معنوياتهم مرتفعه بعض شيء بالزياره
بالزياره التي قام بها همم زين سكي ليله
امس الى باخموت واتكرر بعض الصور مع
الجنود هناك واا السياره التي قام بها
اليوم حيث طار الى واشنطن يقولون انهم
ينتظرون منظومه الدفاع باتريوت بالاضافه
الى الامدادات الامريكيه يعتمدون كثيره في
واشنطن على همم على على ان تجد لهم الحل
على ان تقدم لهم المساعده هنا الاكراديون
يحتاجون الى دعم كبير يحاولون اقناع
الاوروبيين ويحاولوا يقنع كل الدول
الغربيه من اجل ان تقدم لهم همم المساعده
سواء العسكريه او الماديه في هذا الشتاء
القارس شكرا لك عبد القادر
الى اوكرانيا